okay guys from time to time
we've all had one of those moments you
know one of those moments when all the
hard work in the game is done
you've clutched the round already you've
made it to ot you've
almost completed the comeback and all
you gotta do is take
one fairly minor minuscule step over the
finish line
and it's all done and then when you need
it the most
your brain completely shuts off it
happens to the best of us
even the pros and that's why on top tens
today we wanted to take a look
back at those cerebral mishaps that
while deeply horrifying for the players
they happen to
are still pretty funny for us here are
the top 10 times players brains
turn totally off
starting off our list is the unfortunate
moment when kusta's brain
didn't just shut down it totally baited
everyone watching the match he's like oh
better plug everything back in back to
the guys
one more time into the simulation now
kusta is no stranger to making some
weird plays shall we say but this moment
tops
everything on match point against red
reserve clg had the map
in the bag so much so that mike laylee
unplugged his gear
and clg went on to whit wait
what they will pick this up 16-12 they
win out the series
in a 2-1 fashion it was lengthy
but it was no no no oh there was no
time no yep that's kusta
defusing without a kit and to make
matters worse
his team had one you saw they even left
the server michael elliott rusty
disconnected
he was good what just happened his brain
shut off
the bomb blew up and red reserve won the
map
in overtime coming up next
is the kind of brain fart that only a
smash god could produce
he said it's a winner man uh yeah dude
congrats to pbu for taking out mango and
ending his reign of terror
there are only so many people who can be
so good at a game
get so brain dead at the same time and
mango
is that type of player we'll see what
happens mango lucky west balls vs pb
rocky does sound like it should be good
for
for soccer right that's the
match wait was that it
in a literal second mango forgot he was
playing melee
he just fell off the stage and that was
the match
okay well there it is qvu takes out
mango
our number eight entry is a lesson on
why you should always wait a few seconds
before popping off
at evo 2015's guilty gear top 8 what she
gave was sure
he'd just beaten ogawa to advance to the
winner's semi-finals
it was a tense close match and he felt
like he deserved a good pop off
problem was that he didn't actually win
the match
so smart he couldn't burst because of
the super
but will she get dixie
oh my god what she had thought it was
over and stood up and ogawa gave him no
remorse
that is exactly what happens don't have
a celebration with
papa oh my god remember folks
win first pop off
ogawa won the semifinal match eventually
won the evo tournament
as i said he won the tournament yeah the
world's biggest mistake led him to
winning the tournament
taking the number seven spot on our list
is the no brain moment that lost
an lcs final sven knows he messed up and
now
it is on his shoulders to make up for it
the finals of any major tournament is a
very high pressure situation
if you want to make it through you need
quick thinking amazing reactions a sharp
mind
and a little bit of luck unfortunately
for zven his brain was a little too
smooth
in game five of the 2019 spring finals
a fight that goes the right way will
push people down the question is can
they find
those margins can they find that opening
so far tsm has outmaneuvered
no quick silver sash he is down
he is shut down what is he doing to
baron he saw liquid prepping for baron
and probably
ran right into them throwing away his
life the game
the series and the tournament all in one
unfortunate play when sven is under
pressure there he may have cost his team
this series
it's been sitting alone inside his base
the action is gonna fall the rest of his
team is gone
team liquid tie the record it's
three lcs titles in a row they
are the super team
[Applause]
okay it's one thing to turn your brain
off during a high pressure situation
but turning your brain off during the
draft now
that is the kind of moment that deserves
the number six spot
on this list
during the international 2019 alliance
were locked in an elimination match
against rng
and during the draft they completely
forgot
to lock in their pick i will say if i'm
a storm i'd love to be in a situation
where i'm against the lash
as they're going to take the gyrocopter
for themselves so this is going to be an
offlane void
that is true something that we
definitely did not expect
oh my god are you serious
whatever did this just happen
after that blunder alliance did their
best to pull through but it just wasn't
enough
they were eliminated from the tournament
and it was all because they stopped
thinking
at one critical important moment
43 minutes into the game we have
ourselves a match where
both sides really they had their chance
right they had their game plans things
started to come online
obviously the disappointment here for
alliance
at the halfway point on our list is the
most infamous mistake
you can make in overwatch a c9
well i mean they had plenty of people
within range of the point but just
nobody touched it so
named for cloud9's history of hilarious
mistakes a c9 is a verb that describes
when a team bails on the point in
overtime and lets the other team capture
it this is one of those rare moments
when your whole
team goes no brain nano boosts use
they're gonna put that
on to gods it looks like he's got the
whole hog there's a pulse bomb going in
and a couple kills
mendo does get the one onto donghyun
going on to that and it looks like
afrika blue
did they just not touch the point i
guess not and before you ask
yes this brain dead play has been pulled
off by more teams than just c9
but the emp is going to look to shut
down luffy
does have that transcendence ready to go
emp going to come out and
we'll have to get a replay on that one
uh yep please
what happened there i i think that there
was a big old charlie niner
oh young gin oh my god that was actually
a c9
that is a big old c9
smurf is down master is removed it's a
one for
stunned it takes a special kind of brain
to turn off on match point in a grand
final
but canadian pulled it off which is why
this play takes our number four spot
it's the nerves it's gotta be the nerves
i mean
i think we all know that eg's rainbow
six team has developed a reputation
for well throwing the fuser in a
position where they'll have to see when
the habana goes through one will cover
the doorway
as they start to defuse hang he goes for
one on the young can he go the second
they're off the known as the best team
in the world never having that
distinction
until today but this is perhaps the most
brutal throw of all
on game point against team empire
canadian decided to hold white stairs
with his secondary pistol and for some
reason
he peaked shepard will watch that big
window and here comes the tension here
comes the push
down on white stairs waiting for the
vault on in his canadian will he be able
to secure the kill he sees the tracers
go
no scyther will win the fight he'll inch
his way on up geo's gonna be next in
line but this could be a tough shot
and empire could wrestle away the round
there's geo just waiting he doesn't pull
the trigger he sees it he pops up
oh no geo you gotta hit your shots young
will be the last one left
he was so important for faze he turns
his back he's got the pistol
but shepard will deny the comeback from
eg on that round
of course he died for that one and to
make things worse
eg lost the series canadian had to be
wondering where his brain went
at that moment coming in at number three
we have one of league of legends best
players going completely no brain
on the world's biggest stage reckless he
tries to go for the play he goes to the
flash and that ends in his
death playing in the group stage of
worlds 2017 fnatic were matched up
against immortals
in what should have been a relatively
easy match but fnatic were losing
and this play goes a long way in showing
you why
it might just be a huddle up in
defensive here maybe with the
45 seconds on baron oh the story that's
the ultimate though he's the flashback
oh no he doesn't get knocked up he's
done everybody's taking him down again
he gets out of the way but the rest of
the daddy there is
this late in the game those are the
plays that make the definitive
statement rekkles had a little too much
blood in his eyes and he flashed into
his own
death leading to a quick loss for fnatic
this is a disaster for fanatic and then
i'm trying to get something back
only one option left i don't think they
can do the 650 interrupts
they're going to lose they're going to
lose fanatic they can't commit to this
ift they're going to win the games are
exposed this could be bad news the touch
are
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
a moment that will make you
physically recoil an embarrassment you
have
got to be kidding me that's how that
ended oh my goodness i don't know what
to think right now
at the rlcs season 8 world championship
renegades and veloce were 9 minutes into
overtime
renegades had to win to stay in the
tournament back down sick he puts it
away cassio could win the game but comey
has him blocked
and now back in front of the box towards
someone
you're kidding absolute tragedy for
renegades
torsos goes for the save to keep his
team alive but for reasons beyond human
comprehension
sicki puts the ball right back into
renegade's net
giving veloce the game and sending
renegades packing
they're through to day three and
renegades
absolute heartbreaker one they will not
be thinking about they will not forget
for a long time they will
hopefully they'll stop thinking about it
in four years or something my goodness
this honestly just hurts to watch
taking the top spot on our list is the
one the
only one g oh my goodness
there's that oh summit
what's up reddit you had it the infamous
1g
is not only the prime example of a
player's brain switching off during a
match
it's also the most memorable you guys
know the story by now during dreamhack
open austin 2016
summit 1g had secured the last kill on
cutler
and won the map for splice or so
everyone thought and now it's summit in
the 1v1 to try and close this out
against bugley
buggy playing it aggressively know that
it's gonna clutch it
and splice will close out map number one
sixteen to eleven oh wait
what what happened
oh no summit no
oh that is uh heartbreaking and just
like that
a meme was born summit now lives in
infamy in cs history forever
all thanks to one smooth brained play
well guys that about does it for the top
10 times players brains
turned off during a match now your brain
would have to be turned off if you don't
immediately go to twitch.tv the score
esports
give us a follow and turn notifications
on because we are going live
all the time on twitch now with a
completely new roster of unique
live shows you should check it out i'll
be there
this is a message for all you punk kids
out there
with your crunchyroll subscriptions
and your netflix animes back in the day
if you wanted to watch some anime you
had to go down to your local video store
and you had to rent one of these bad
boys bhs tapes baby that was the only
way
and guaranteed they had like seven
episodes out of 50.
my parents just thought it was an
innocent cartoon little did they know it
is the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you could rent at
blockbuster